how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
and things have been great lately for
mcu fans phase four of the mcu has
officially started we are waiting for
the next episode
of wandavision this friday and we
finally have some leaked photos for
thor love and thunder involving the
actual actors not just
of the set and even though just simply
seeing the actors back on set
in their costumes is super exciting it
actually does look like we have at least
one big reveal from these league set
photos about thor himself
now in this photo right here we have
star-lord and thor together which was
expected when we last left the two of
them in avengers end game at the end
thor left with the guardians of the
galaxy so it would only make sense that
thor love and thunder picked up
right after where avengers end game left
off or at least not too long after it
they may have gotten into some
shenanigans already but we're definitely
going to join them
when thor is with the guardians and as
you can see here star-lord
has somewhat of a new look he's now
rocking a pretty long cloak
that looks really awesome he has some
gauntlets on he has some type of
shoulder pads on
overall just a really upgraded cool look
and thor
looks kind of retro and he actually
looks like he's
almost kind of wearing his original og
thor costume with the blue pants and the
yellow boots
perhaps the whole entire original outfit
will come together at some point in thor
love and thunder now
possibly the biggest thing to take away
from this photo is that
chris hemsworth is not wearing a thor
fat suit
he is in shape no cgi effects on him
anything like that he's not wearing a
mocap suit so it looks like thor
is back in shape this is something that
we'll most likely see at the very
beginning of the movie
and star-lord is most likely going to
join him on this fitness journey as well
if you consider the fact that in
avengers in-game all the other guardians
were kind of making fun of star-lord
for being out of shape so thor being fat
and out of shape was probably really
funny for star-lord to see but of course
when thor starts to get back in shape
star-lord is going to want to be pretty
competitive with him and he's going to
want to be the one in better shape
and judging based off of what director
taiko atiti said about how the film is
going to be i wouldn't be surprised if
we got some sort of a workout montage in
the beginning of the film
with thor and star-lord working out
together trying to get into shape
now of course thor is the god of thunder
and an asgardian
so he could probably get back in shape
in like a day or two whereas star-lord
doesn't really have that
so expect some funny moments there but
another thing to notice is that thor
looks very
retro almost like an 80s style type of
vibe going on here and this is most
likely due to him
listening to star-lord's music or
perhaps just new music in general that
star-lord and thor get into together but
we know music is a big part for
star-lord and taika likes to go very big
with the music so this retro look is
very suiting for thor
thor's hair has been cut a little bit
it's not nearly as long as
fat thor in avengers end game and it's
no longer braided like it was
overall it kind of looks like thor has
basically gotten his life back together
now as far as the rest of the guardians
of the galaxy are concerned it's pretty
much confirmed that they are all going
to be in thor love and thunder and we
even have this
leak set photo of nebula confirming that
she will indeed be
in the movie i think she was the only
one we didn't have confirmation for
except for gamora we're still not sure
if zoe saldana is going to appear
in thor love and thunder we know that
she'll probably appear in guardians of
the galaxy vol
3 but we're still not sure about thor
love and thunder but the rest of the
guardians are there
nebula doesn't look too different it
almost looks like she's wearing slightly
different clothes
but based off of this leak set photo
it's hard to tell if this is actually a
part of the costume or if it's just
karen gillan or her stunt double
casually walking around the set trying
to be comfortable then in this last
leaked set photo we have sean gunn in
the left side of the photo he's partly
cut off but sean gunn the brother of
james gunn the director of the guardians
films who does the mo-cap for
rocket raccoon but if you look at him in
this photo he is dressed in his usual
gear leading me to believe that he is
actually going to be playing craglin and
that's pretty interesting because we
didn't see kraglin in infinity war or
guardians of the galaxy
but in guardians of the galaxy 2 it did
look like he was going to be a part of
the guardians he even had yondu's arrow
at the end so it looked like he was
going to play a pretty big role in
guardians 3.
now again he's slightly cut off but you
can see that something is on top of his
head
this could be something that he's
wearing to control the arrow much like
yondu wore his fin
we'll have to wait till the movie to
find out but it does look like craiglin
will be a part of the guardians of the
galaxy and last but not least there is
some crazy type of car
in this photo now this kind of does seem
to be like
it's used for filming it's a filming
vehicle but
who knows taika watiti did say that thor
love and thunder was going to be
bigger than thor ragnarok and it's
already confirmed that we're going to be
having some space sharks in the movie as
well
so if some crazy cool space cars showed
up it wouldn't surprise me in the
slightest
so there you have it our first leaked
photos for
thor love and thunder thor is back in
shape and still with the guardians of
the galaxy so let me know in the
comments down below what you think is
going to happen
in thor love and thunder and be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest thor 4
news don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and
instagram as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
me
you